Katrina:  然后我们有那种大音箱不
Katrina: And then, do we have those big speakers?
Shure:  这个可以有
Shure: That can be arranged.
Katrina:  如果在外面玩的话放点音乐啥
Katrina: If we play outside, let's put on some music.
Jake: 嗯就放刚刚那个曲子
Katrina: Yeah, just play that track we had earlier.
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Katrina:  嗯大东北
Katrina: Yeah, the Northeast.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Katrina:  知识问答自我介绍
Katrina: Knowledge quiz, self-introduction.
Jake: 打死我吧
Jake: Kill me now.
Jake: 这个花瓶
Jake: This vase.
Katrina:  这是真的酒还是假酒
Katrina: Is this real wine or fake wine?
Jake: 假酒
Jake: Fake wine.
Katrina: 啊我还以为你们已经喝了
Katrina: Ah, I thought you guys already drank it.
Jake: 这是我的水瓶
Jake: This is my water bottle.
Jake: 没有啥毛病哦
Jake: Nothing wrong with it.
Lucia: 嗯，哦那个酒啊
Lucia: Hmm, oh that wine.
Katrina:  再拿起出来干一口
Katrina: Take another sip from it.
Jake: 那花瓶拿走了还倒
Jake: The vase was taken away and still poured.
Katrina:  这多的话等会就放
Katrina: If there's more, just put it later.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Katrina:  这花瓶好
Katrina: This vase is good.
Lucia: 小心
Lucia: Be careful.
Shure: 完了
Shure: It's over.
Shure:  这是个保温杯啊
Shure: This is a thermos bottle.
Lucia: 啊这居然是保温杯
Lucia: Ah, it's actually a thermos.
Shure:  一听就是304不锈钢
Shure: You can tell it's 304 stainless steel.
Jake: 呵呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 厉害了
Lucia: Impressive.
Jake: 很懂啊大东北
Jake: Really knowledgeable, Northeast.
Jake: 衬衫的是吧
Jake: Is it the shirt?
Jake: 东北钢铁厂
Jake: Northeast steel mill.
Shure:  安钢
Shure: Angang.
Shure:  这字写的太好看了
Shure: The writing is so beautiful.
Shure:  真的
Shure: Really.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Shure:  可歌可泣
Shure: So touching.
Jake: 一看就是中文
Jake: You can tell it's Chinese.
Shure:  哦我们还要写个英文版吗
Shure: Oh, should we write an English version too?
Jake:: 不用不用不用
Jake: 哎呦对
Jake: Oh, right.
Jake: 我们字写的好
Jake: Our writing is good.
Shure: : 我们应该international一点
Shure:  你看我那个英文就明显跟这个
Shure: You see, my English is obviously different from this.
Jake: 那好下面开始写英文吧
Jake: Alright, let's start writing in English then.
Jake: OK
Jake:时间线
Jake: Timeline
Jake: 来
Jake: Come on
Shure: 来咱俩换一下
Shure: Let's switch places.
Shure:  你去那边坐一会去
Shure: You go sit over there for a while.
Jake: 或坐这
Jake: Or sit here.
Shure:  timeline
Shure: Timeline
Jake:为啥是俩词
Jake: Why is it two words?
Alice: 时间线吧
Alice: Timeline, right?
Jake: 为啥是俩词
Jake: Why is it two words?
Jake: 这个
Jake: This one.
Jake: 这个也行
Jake: This one works too.
Jake:也行也行
Jake: Also works, also works.
Shure:  强调一下这个life
Shure: Emphasize this part, "life".
Jake:好好
Jake: Okay, okay.
Shure: 线
Shure: Line.
Shure:  首先我们几点入场
Shure: First of all, what time are we entering?
Jake: 3点 3点吧
Jake: 3 o'clock, 3 o'clock.
Jake: 应该是2点到3点逐步入场
Jake: It should be gradual entry from 2 to 3 o'clock.
Jake: 然后前面可能签到的人
Jake: Then maybe people will check in first.
Katrina: 逛逛
Katrina: Walk around.
Jake: 对给他们一点活动
Jake: Yeah, give them some activities.
Shure:  鹌鹑
Shure: Quail.
Jake:哈哈神经
Jake: Haha, you're crazy.
Shure:  入场是怎么拍的吗
Shure: How are we filming the entry?
Lucia: 2点半到3点
Lucia: From 2:30 to 3:00.
Shure:  okay对
Jake: Okay, right.
Shure:  这意思就是3点之前
Jake: This means before 3 o'clock.
Shure:  我们搞一些flexible的游戏或者活动
Jake: We'll have some flexible games or activities.
Shure:  然后3点准时干点什么东西
Jake: Then exactly at 3, we'll do something.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  game
Shure: Game.
Shure:  before
Shure: Before.
Shure:  是不是污染数据
Shure: Isn't this data contamination?
Lucia: 这是不是有个
Lucia: Isn't there a...
Jake: 不污染
Jake: No contamination.
Jake: 这是人类的正常行为
Jake: This is normal human behavior.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  还有什么
Shure: What else?
Jake: 然后3点干啥了
Jake: And then what happens at 3 o'clock?
Katrina:  3点开始就有知识问答和自我介绍
Katrina: Starting at 3, there will be a Q&A and self-introductions.
Shure:  那这这些呢
Shure: What about these?
Katrina:  这些就是我们要让他们先获得货币
Katrina: For these, we need to make sure they get some currency first.
Katrina:  以后我们再推销我们自己的产品
Katrina: Then we can start promoting our products.
Katrina:  我其实感觉不确定
Katrina: Honestly, I'm not sure.
Katrina:  他们到底是E人还是I人
Katrina: Are they E-types or I-types?
Katrina:  你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina:  就万一
Katrina: Just in case.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Katrina:  其实可能不会持续很长的时间
Katrina: It might not last very long, actually.
Katrina:  自我介绍
Katrina: The self-introductions.
Katrina: 知识问答40分钟吧
Katrina: The Q&A will be about 40 minutes.
Katrina:  加自我介绍
Katrina: Plus the self-introductions.
Shure:  您说也行
Shure: If you say so.
Jake: 抢答对吧
Jake: Quick responses, right?
Katrina:  嗯很快其实
Katrina: Yeah, it's pretty quick, actually.
Jake: 对对挺好
Jake: Yes, yes, that's good.
Shure:  and知识问答
Shure: And the Q&A.
Katrina: QA
Katrina: QA.
Shure: 嗷
Shure: Oh.
Jake:妙啊
Jake: Brilliant.
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK.
Shure:  第3点
Shure: The third point.
Katrina:  然后就每个人介绍自己做的这个
Katrina: Then everyone will introduce their own projects.
Katrina:  然后就跟他们说
Katrina: And we'll tell them that...
Katrina:  他们可以拿他们的货币来
Katrina: they can use their currency...
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake:大家插会电吧
Jake: Let's plug in for a bit.
Jake: 来你们继续聊
Jake: You guys keep chatting.
Jake: 我给大家发线
Jake: I'll distribute the cables.
Katrina:  40
Katrina: 40.
Shure:  可以  然后呢
Shure: Alright, and then?
Jake: 哦你一直插着的
Jake: Oh, you've been plugged in all along.
Shure:  我一直插着充电宝
Shure: I've been using the power bank.
Jake: 礼物
Jake: Gifts.
Jake: 这个是谁的
Jake: Whose is this?
Katrina:  我我的
Katrina: It's mine.
Jake: 好那你插上吧少一个
Jake: Okay, then you plug it in, we're missing one.
Lucia: 我也插上了
Lucia: I plugged mine in too.
Shure:  3
Shure: 3
Katrina: 介绍自己的产品吗
Katrina: Introduce our own products?
Katrina:  每个人
Katrina: Everyone?
Shure:  啊3就开始拍卖
Shure: Ah, at 3 we start the auction.
Shure:  怎么说
Shure: How do you say it?
Shure:  怎么说auction
Shure: How do you say auction?
Lucia: auction
Lucia: Auction.
Jake: 你也插一个吧
Jake: You plug one in too.
Alice: 哦谢谢
Alice: Oh, thanks.
Jake: OK谢谢
Shure:  预计3:40到
Shure: Estimated arrival at 3:40.
Lucia: 一个小时 或许
Lucia: An hour maybe.
Shure:  4点半吧差不多
Shure: Around 4:30, probably.
Katrina:  你这拍卖
Katrina: Your auction...
Katrina:  指的是拍卖他们自己带带的东西
Katrina: You mean auctioning off the stuff they brought?
Katrina:  还是谁来拍卖
Katrina: Or who will be auctioning?
Shure:  自己的和
Shure: Their own and...
Katrina: 他们自己带的
Katrina: The stuff they brought.
Katrina:  对和我们的
Katrina: Yeah, and ours.
Lucia: 和咱们的产品都可以吧
Lucia: And our products too, right?
Katrina:  那应该不止一个小时吧
Katrina: That should take more than an hour then.
Lucia: 不止吗那就再长一个半小时
Lucia: More than an hour? Then add another half hour.
Katrina:  一个半小时差不多
Katrina: An hour and a half should be enough.
Katrina:  主要是看他们
Katrina: It mainly depends on them.
Shure: 我们可以细分
Shure: We can split it.
Shure:  这个是他们自己的部分
Shure: This is their own part.
Shure:  这是guest part
Shure: This is the guest part.
Lucia: 这些这些
Lucia: These, these...
Lucia: 这些gets
Lucia: These gets...
Lucia: 他们带多少东西
Lucia: How much stuff they brought.
Lucia: 以及他们是I人还是E人
Lucia: And whether they are introverts or extroverts.
Katrina:  对这就不确定
Katrina: Yeah, that's uncertain.
Shure:  呃然后还有什么我们的
Shure: Uh, what else do we have?
Shure:  或者我们可以提前来
Shure: Or we can come early.
Shure:  活跃一下这个气氛
Shure: To liven up the atmosphere.
Katrina:  嗯对
Katrina: Yeah, right.
Katrina:  我觉得我们先开始吧
Katrina: I think we should start first.
Shure:  我们先开始
Shure: Let's start first.
Katrina:  3:40到4点半
Katrina: From 3:40 to 4:30.
Katrina:  是我们先开始
Katrina: We should start first.
Shure:  我们
Shure: We...
Katrina: 每个人
Katrina: Everyone...
Shure: 会会这么
Shure: Will...
Katrina: 七八分钟差不多
Katrina: About seven to eight minutes.
Katrina:  七八分钟
Katrina: Seven to eight minutes.
Katrina:  那40分钟差不多
Katrina: So about 40 minutes in total.
Katrina:  那就4:20
Katrina: That would be around 4:20.
Katrina:  那就4:204:20吧
Katrina: Let's make it 4:20.
Shure: 4:20吧
Shure: 4:20 works.
Lucia: 或者
Lucia: Or...
Lucia: 直接把他们把这段变成我们整体的
Lucia: We could turn this part into our overall...
Lucia: 一个
Lucia: A...
Lucia: 怎么形容一个小续集也行
Lucia: How to describe it, a small sequel.
Lucia: 就是可以让他们先
Lucia: We could let them go first.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Right.
Lucia: 就是如果对咱们整体的这个手工制品
Lucia: If it fits into our overall handcrafted item.
Lucia: 感觉就好比我们是一个商家一样
Lucia: It feels like we're a vendor.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm.
Lucia: 嗯只不过使用的是这个虚拟货币
Lucia: We're just using virtual currency.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Right.
Lucia: 然后如果大家玩的比较高兴的
Lucia: If everyone is having fun...
Lucia: 话就后面让他们在自己之间交换
Lucia: Then let them exchange among themselves later.
Katrina:  都行
Katrina: That works.
Lucia: 也可以
Lucia: That can work too.
Alice:反正现在我们买了花瓶嘛
Alice: Anyway, we bought the vases.
Katrina:  对对对我买6个
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, I bought six.
Alice: 还有在哪呢
Alice: Where are they?
Katrina:  人家都到了
Katrina: They all arrived.
Katrina:  但是这花可以让他们自己插
Katrina: But they can arrange the flowers themselves.
Alice: 就是现在不是行花吗
Alice: Isn't it about arranging flowers?
Katrina:  嗯就是
Katrina: Yeah, it is.
Katrina:  我的意思是
Katrina: What I mean is...
Katrina:  可以大家自己搭配自己挑嘛
Katrina: They can pick and match themselves.
Alice: 哦你的意思是
Alice: Oh, you mean...
Katrina: 六六个瓶子吗
Katrina: Six vases?
Katrina:  然后多的就放这种公共的
Katrina: And the rest in the common area.
Katrina:  刚才还有花瓶啥的
Katrina: There were vases and stuff just now.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yeah.
Alice:先醒醒他吧
Alice: Let's wake him up first.
Jake: 我们的食品环节吃饭环下午茶环节
Jake: Our food segment, eating segment, and afternoon tea segment.
Jake: 在什么地方
Jake: Where are they?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure:  啊要有一直有一个酒保在那边
Shure: Ah, there should be a bartender over there.
Lucia:  哈哈哈一直有一个酒保
Lucia: Hahaha, always a bartender.
Jake: 那酒保在什么位置呢
Jake: So, where should the bartender be?
Katrina:  我感觉就外面这里已经很好了
Jake: I feel like outside here is already good.
Jake: 那调酒是在外面
Jake: So the mixing happens outside.
Katrina:  但是但是但是我喝酒
Katrina: But, but, but I drink...
Lucia: 或者调酒是在这个台子上调
Lucia: Or the mixing can happen on this counter.
Jake: 也可以啊在室内然后如果有人
Jake: That's fine too, indoors, and if someone...
Shure: 就在这
Shure: Just here.
Shure:  哇
Shure: Wow.
Lucia: 对刚好可以表演就是待在外面的
Lucia: Yeah, it would be perfect for a performance, just stay outside.
Lucia: 玻璃就可以看到
Lucia: The glass can show...
Lucia: 调酒师在里面
Lucia: The bartender inside.
Lucia: 如何调哇好高级啊
Lucia: How they mix, wow, it's so high-end.
Jake:对是是
Jake: Yes, yes.
Lucia: 来来一点打光
Lucia: Let's add some lighting.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 对我们还有这个影棚灯
Lucia: We also have the studio lights.
Lucia: 虽然这个我们是就一个
Lucia: Although we only have one light.
Lucia: 一个灯吗
Lucia: One light, right?
Jake: 没有四个啊
Jake: No, we have four.
Lucia: 啊OK
Lucia: Ah, OK.
Jake:现在还没装晚一会装一下
Jake: We haven't set them up yet, we'll set them up later.
Katrina:  那那下午茶时间要不要弄到4:20之后
Katrina: So, should we have afternoon tea after 4:20?
Katrina:  要不然插在哪个地方
Katrina: Or else, where do we fit it in?
Shure: 可以大家边吃边干嘛
Shure: We can eat while doing other things.
Lucia: 就我觉得4:20之后就可以
Lucia: I think after 4:20 is fine.
Lucia: 因为一般来说
Lucia: Because generally,
Lucia: 下午茶就是3点到5点这个时 间段
Lucia: Afternoon tea is between 3:00 and 5:00.
Jake: 就可能我们一一部分人
Jake: So maybe some of us...
Jake: 还是我们先做好
Jake: Or we should do it first.
Jake: 我们可以先做好吗
Jake: Can we get it ready first?
Alice: 什么
Alice: What?
Jake:就是那些
Jake: Those...
Katrina: 甜品
Katrina: Desserts.
Jake:甜品
Jake: Desserts.
Tasha:  可以啊
Tasha: Okay.
Jake: 可以啊可以先做好
Jake: Yeah, we can prepare them first.
Jake:可以先做好
Jake: We can prepare them first.
Katrina:  哎那就是反正他他他的是种子片
Katrina: Well, anyway, his is a seed collection.
Katrina:  就加甜品
Katrina: Just add desserts.
Katrina:  就在3:40-4:20介绍
Katrina: Introduce it between 3:40-4:20.
Katrina:  然后他作为我们几个的压轴
Katrina: And then he's the finale for us.
Katrina:  然后介绍完了以后大家可以分发一下
Katrina: After the introduction, everyone can distribute and taste his desserts.
Katrina:  尝一下他的那个甜品
Katrina: Try his desserts.
Katrina:  对他们上一个环节
Katrina: For their last session.
Katrina:  也有钱了嘛
Katrina: They also had money, right?
Tasha: 甜品摆台吗
Tasha: Dessert table display?
Alice: 摆台吗摆台吗
Alice: Table display? Table display?
Jake: 摆什么
Jake: Display what?
Tasha: 甜品摆台
Tasha: Dessert table display.
Lucia: 那种三层塔的，那种懂吗
Lucia: The three-tier kind, you know?
Alice: 啊啊
Tasha: Ohhh.
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Alice: 看一下就觉得好看当然可以了
Alice: Just looking at it makes it seem nice, of course it can.
Lucia: 哇，好漂亮
Lucia: Wow, it's so pretty.
Tasha: 嗯好的
Tasha: Hmm, okay.
Tasha: 那就是甜品台做一次要800-1,000呢
Tasha: So a dessert table setup costs about 800-1,000.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha.
Shure:  怎么杨老板突然空手了
Shure: Why is Jake suddenly empty-handed?
Shure:  应该是哈哈哈
Shure: Should be, hahaha.
Jake: 可以可以可以
Jake: It's possible, possible.
Tasha: 没有只是买个甜品台架子
Tasha: No, just buy a dessert table stand.
Jake: 架子1,000是吧
Jake: The stand is 1,000, right?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Jake:那是什么
Jake: Then what is it?
Alice: 总共的吧
Alice: Total, I guess.
Jake: 总共500-1,000
Jake: Total is 500-1,000.
Tasha: 就是你你去做的话
Tasha: If you go and do it.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 去外面吗
Shure: Outside?
Katrina:  哎但是你需不需要很多机器啊
Katrina: Hey, but do you need a lot of machines?
Tasha: 嗯基础的买了
Tasha: Hmm, bought the basics.
Tasha: 厨师机什么的肯定没买
Tasha: Definitely didn't buy things like a stand mixer.
Jake: 能能多少钱
Jake: How much would it cost?
Tasha:  嗯不能买
Tasha: Hmm, can't buy it.
Jake: 呵呵呵不能买是什么
Tasha: Haha, what do you mean can't buy it?
Jake: 太贵了嗯
Jake: Too expensive, yeah.
Tasha: 对啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 呵呵
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:上万
Jake: Over ten thousand.
Tasha: 嗯几千块钱吧
Tasha: Hmm, it's a few thousand.
Jake: OK嗯可以
Jake: OK, sounds good.
Tasha: 甜品台就类似这样子哦
Tasha: The dessert table would be something like this.
Katrina:  啊看一眼好漂亮啊
Katrina: Ah, it's so pretty at a glance.
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 它差不多是我设想的那种好漂亮
Lucia: It's almost what I envisioned, so pretty.
Tasha: 到时候坐在这里
Tasha: When the time comes, sit here.
Lucia: 我每次开学术会议的时候就是这样
Lucia: Every time I have an academic conference, it's like this.
Tasha: 就是哈哈哈
Tasha: Exactly, hahaha.
Katrina:  邪兽蝗虫
Katrina: Academic locusts.
Lucia: 对对对，学术蝗虫
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, academic locusts.
Tasha: 是这样的
Tasha: That's right.
Tasha: 哈哈哈可以这样子的
Tasha: Hahaha, it can be like that.
Lucia: 而且关键是老师一般都不怎么吃
Lucia: And the key is that the teachers usually don't eat much.
Lucia: 结果都是我吃
Lucia: So I end up eating it all.
Jake: 还打包打了一包回去
Jake: And you even packed some to take home.
Jake: 烧烤吗
Jake: BBQ?
Katrina:  烧烤偏晚上吧
Katrina: BBQ is more for the evening.
Jake: 晚上再吃
Jake: Eat it at night then.
Katrina:  那就是但是你要留他们到晚上的话
Katrina: But if you want to keep them till the evening,
Katrina:  这个晚饭怎么弄
Katrina: what about dinner?
Shure:  大家一起烤呗
Shure: Everyone can grill together.
Shure:  一起吃烧烤
Shure: Eat BBQ together.
Shure:  一起吃这个是吗
Shure: Eat this together, right?
Jake: 一起吃什么烧烤的人有点累哦
Jake: Eating BBQ together can be tiring.
Katrina:  因为有20个人左右
Katrina: Because there are about 20 people.
Lucia: 如果来的人多的话
Lucia: If a lot of people come,
Lucia: 就是都烧烤还挺麻麻烦的
Lucia: grilling for everyone can be quite troublesome.
Katrina:  嗯确实而且包饭也麻烦
Katrina: Yeah, and preparing rice is also a hassle.
Katrina:  点外卖也麻烦
Katrina: Ordering takeout is such a hassle.
Lucia: 确实
Lucia: Totally.
Katrina:  那个点披萨倒是还行
Katrina: But getting pizza is pretty okay.
Lucia: 对就是可能每人吃那么一两块
Lucia: Yeah, everyone can just have a slice or two.
Lucia: 也不是说要吃的非常饱嘛
Lucia: It's not like we need to get super full.
Shure:  蘸点披萨
Shure: Dip some pizza.
Shure:  有那个32寸这么大
Shure: There's one that's like 32 inches big.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 行行
Jake: Sure, sure.
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: Sounds good.
Katrina:  就到了午饭的点就摆在这
Katrina: Just have it here around lunchtime.
Katrina:  对大家饿了自己五点吃
Katrina: Then if anyone's hungry, they can eat at five.
Lucia: 而且如果之前
Lucia: Plus, if we had...
Lucia: 有
Lucia: some...
Lucia: 吃甜的东西的话可能也不会特别的饿
Lucia: sweet stuff earlier, we wouldn't be too hungry.
Jake: 是的是的
Jake: True, true.
Jake: 那就5点半的时候
Jake: So at 5:30...
Jake: 一个大披萨
Jake: we'll have a big pizza.
Katrina:  嗯现在是5点
Katrina: Hmm, it's 5 o'clock now.
Katrina:  嗯 5点
Katrina: Yeah, 5 o'clock.
Lucia: 我们现在到五点了
Lucia: We're at 5 o'clock now.
Katrina:  那我们的节目就弄到晚上一样
Katrina: So our show will go into the evening.
Katrina:  因为我当时想的是
Katrina: Because I was thinking...
Katrina:  你那个讲故事的话大家不是很熟
Katrina: if you tell stories, people might not be very familiar.
Katrina:  因为你那个讲故事设定在酒吧
Katrina: Because your storytelling is set in a bar.
Katrina:  根据酒吧大家都是有故事的人
Katrina: In a bar, everyone has stories to tell.
Katrina:  可能就在那种环境下
Katrina: Maybe in that kind of environment,
Katrina:  然后就愿意讲
Katrina: people are willing to share.
Katrina:  但是我们这种刚过来
Katrina: But for us who just got here,
Katrina:  他们可能不太愿意讲故事
Katrina: they might not want to tell stories.
Katrina:  所以改成自我介绍还挺好
Katrina: So switching to self-introductions is good.
Katrina:  然后
Katrina: And then...
Katrina:  如果说要讲故事或获金币这个环节
Katrina: if we have a storytelling or coin-earning segment,
Katrina:  我觉得可以弄到偏晚上1点
Katrina: I think we can do that around 1 AM.
Katrina:  大家已经熟了一点
Katrina: When people are more familiar.
Katrina:  再加上晚上比较感性
Katrina: Plus, at night, people are more emotional.
Katrina:  可以带着一点自己的故事过来
Katrina: They can bring their own stories.
Katrina:  然后那
Katrina: And then...
Katrina:  那就5点
Katrina: so at 5...
Katrina:  是他们介绍完他们的pass
Katrina: after they finish introducing their pass.
Katrina:  然后5点到6点就吃烧烤调酒这种吗
Katrina: So from 5 to 6 we’ll have BBQ and cocktails, right?
Katrina:  其实他并不会完全严格的按照这个
Katrina: Actually, he won't follow this strictly.
Katrina:  对所以可以搞个5点到6点的区间
Katrina: Yeah, so we can set a range from 5 to 6.
Shure:  反正开饭dinner
Shure: Anyway, we start dinner.
Shure:  在5点半之后
Shure: After 5:30.
Shure:  5点半左右嗯
Shure: Around 5:30, yeah.
Jake: 大披萨
Jake: A big pizza.
Jake: a bow
Jake: A bow.
Jake: 第一个披萨
Jake: The first pizza.
Katrina:  第一个披萨还有BBQ
Katrina: The first pizza and BBQ.
Shure:  bbq
Shure: BBQ.
Katrina:  那调酒的话是属于贯穿始终
Katrina: And cocktails will be served throughout, right?
Shure:  对就像甜品和
Shure: Yeah, just like desserts and...
Katrina:  就是他们入场的时候是ert吧
Katrina: So they come in during the ERT, right?
Shure:  嗯还是SS
Shure: Hmm, or SS.
Lucia:SS好像
Lucia: I think it’s SS.
Katrina:  哦你说甜品啊
Katrina: Oh, you mean the desserts.
Shure:  and
Shure: And...
Katrina:  那晚上就还剩啥
Katrina: So what’s left for the evening?
Katrina:  我想想还剩我们的节目
Katrina: Let me think... our program.
Jake: 对我们有
Jake: Yes, we have...
Katrina:  然后也不能弄太晚
Katrina: And it can’t be too late.
Katrina:  他们回去的话要两个小时
Katrina: It takes them two hours to get back.
Katrina:  嗯那我们就定个结束时间
Katrina: Hmm, so let’s set an end time.
Jake: 8点可以
Jake: 8 PM can be the deadline.
Katrina:  2点半到8点差不多了
Katrina: 2:30 to 8 should be enough.
Katrina:  忙够呛了
Katrina: That’s busy enough.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina:  跟戴娜差不多
Katrina: Similar to Dana's.
Katrina:  到6点半
Katrina: Till 6:30.
Katrina:  然后还有一个半小时就是表演
Katrina: And then we have an hour and a half for performances.
Katrina:  表演节目
Katrina: Performances.
Katrina:  能让他们也准备点节目吗
Katrina: Can we ask them to prepare something too?
Katrina:  有没有那种擅长唱歌的
Katrina: Anyone good at singing?
Shure:  可以反正我们又挖吉他
Shure: Sure, we have a guitar anyway.
Katrina:  嗯对
Katrina: Yeah, right.
Katrina:  啊唱唱歌跳跳舞
Katrina: Ah, singing and dancing.
Jake: 对时间太长了
Jake: Yeah, it’s too long.
Lucia: 来一个大家一起卡拉OK的环节吧
Lucia: How about a karaoke session for everyone?
Katrina:  哪个时间太长
Katrina: Which part is too long?
Jake: 不是不是
Jake: No, no, no.
Jake: 我我我是说中间可能有一个小时
Jake: I-I-I mean there might be an hour in between.
Jake: 我们要传数据
Jake: We need to transfer the data.
Jake: 你们的眼睛
Jake: Your eyes...
Katrina:  陈数军让他们自己逛逛我们的世界
Katrina: Chen Shu-Jun let them explore our world.
Katrina:  然后喝点酒
Katrina: And then have some drinks.
Lucia: 传数据的时候带大家唱唱歌好了
Lucia: While transferring data, let's sing some songs with everyone.
Shure:  free time在这放一个小电影或者干嘛的
Shure: During free time, we can play a short film or something.
Shure:  小电影对对对
Shure: A short film, yes, yes.
Lucia: 小电影可以
Lucia: A short film would be good.
Jake: 中间中间空一个小时差大概
Jake: Leave an hour in between.
Shure:  对当时还说那个就3点什么时候
Shure: Yeah, we also mentioned that it would be around 3 o'clock.
Shure:  6点纪录片什么的
Shure: And then a documentary at 6 o'clock or something.
Katrina:  那就是那个5点结束之后呗
Katrina: So that's after it ends at 5 o'clock, right?
Jake: 对啊他家吃披萨时候咱就不拍了吧
Jake: Yeah, we won't film while they eat pizza at his place.
Tasha: 行甜品是什么
Tasha: Okay, what's for dessert?
Lucia: 也可以
Lucia: That works too.
Tasha: 哪个时间段吃甜品
Tasha: What time will we have dessert?
Katrina:  甜品是你就是我
Katrina: Dessert is you, it's me.
Katrina:  host host part就是他们一二环节
Katrina: Host part, that's their first and second segment.
Katrina:  不是会得金币吗
Katrina: Aren't they supposed to get coins?
Katrina:  然后3:40到4:20的时候
Katrina: And then from 3:40 to 4:20,
Katrina:  我们介绍我们的产品
Katrina: we'll introduce our product.
Katrina:  然后我想的是你放在最后
Katrina: And I thought we could do that last.
Katrina:  然后就是刚好这个part结束了
Katrina: So when this part ends,
Katrina:  以后大家就可以尝你的甜品
Katrina: everyone can taste your dessert.
Tasha: 4:20 对
Tasha: 4:20, right.
Katrina:  就是你压轴
Katrina: You'll be the finale.
Katrina:  哈哈你介绍你的种子片和你的甜品
Katrina: Haha, you introduce your seeds and your dessert.
Katrina:  我们介绍我们自己做的种
Katrina: We'll introduce the seeds we made ourselves.
Shure:  可以嗯
Shure: Sounds good, yeah.
Jake: 3点到5点两个小时够
Jake: Two hours from 3 to 5 should be enough.
Jake: 挺好大概从早上就要开始准备
Jake: Pretty good, we should start preparing in the morning.
Tasha: 然后需要配两个人
Tasha: And we'll need two people to assist.
Tasha: 可以我可以帮忙
Tasha: I can help.
Katrina:  哈哈哈就想写
Katrina: Hahaha, I just wanted to write.
Tasha: 哈哈哈配两个人
Tasha: Hahaha, two people to assist.
Shure: 真的起得来吗
Shure: Can you really get up?
Katrina:  可以的我今天只是失误
Katrina: Yes, today was just a mistake.
Katrina:  哈哈哈到时候死都没想到
Katrina: Hahaha, you won't believe what happens then.
Shure:  我听到了你的闹钟
Shure: I heard your alarm.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Katrina:  不是你怎么听到
Katrina: How did you hear it?
Katrina:  你不是住一楼吗
Katrina: Aren't you on the first floor?
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yeah.
Shure:  因为咱俩应该就是差不多上上下这种
Shure: Because we're pretty much right above and below each other.
Shure:  啊你那个跟我是一样的
Shure: Ah, your alarm is just like mine.
Lucia: 不过也正常
Lucia: But that's normal.
Lucia: 我我我本科舍友回我早晨定的闹铃
Lucia: My college roommate would set an alarm in the morning.
Lucia: 我舍友都醒了
Lucia: It'd wake everyone up.
Lucia: 我自己还没醒
Lucia: Except me.
Shure: 自己就听不见
Shure: You just can't hear your own alarm.
Katrina:  嗯明天定三个
Katrina: Hmm, set three alarms tomorrow.
Katrina:  那就差不多想想啊
Katrina: That should be enough, right?
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake: 所以那一天的甜品是要当天做
Jake: So, do we make the dessert on the same day?
Jake: 还是可以前一天做
Jake: Or can we make it the day before?
Tasha: 有的需要冷藏的会前一天做
Tasha: Some that need refrigeration can be made the day before.
Tasha: 比如提拉米苏
Tasha: Like tiramisu.
Katrina:  哎其实像那种
Katrina: Oh, actually, for those...
Katrina:  就是我看他们那种清补凉那种
Katrina: I've seen them make those refreshing desserts.
Katrina:  是不是就买点椰奶然后做点圆
Katrina: You just buy some coconut milk and make some tapioca.
Tasha: 清补凉的话
Tasha: For refreshing desserts,
Katrina: 那是不是好调一点啊
Katrina: Isn't it easier to adjust the taste?
Tasha: 也是前一天做好
Tasha: You make it the day before.
Tasha: 然后第二天就直接把原料
Tasha: Then the next day, just use the ingredients.
Tasha: 然后进行一个配就行
Tasha: Just mix them together.
Tasha: 对对对就是
Tasha: Yeah, yeah, just...
Tasha: 用那个吉利丁片和椰奶
Tasha: Use gelatin sheets and coconut milk.
Tasha: 就可以做
Tasha: And you can make it.
Tasha: 好像
Tasha: Seems like.
Katrina:  哦
Katrina: Oh.
Katrina:  我看他们有的那种糖水就是直接椰奶
Katrina: I've seen some of those desserts with just coconut milk.
Katrina:  然后加一点水果
Katrina: And a bit of fruit.
Katrina:  加一点芋圆就行了
Katrina: And some taro balls.
Katrina:  感觉那样会不会简单一点
Katrina: Wouldn't that be simpler?
Katrina:  就不要做成那种冻不起的那种
Katrina: Just don't make it into a jelly-like thing.
Katrina:  就不要用那个什么吉利饮片
Katrina: Just don't use those gelatin sheets.
Tasha: 那清不了好吃吗
Tasha: Would it taste good?
Tasha: 你觉得
Tasha: Do you think?
Katrina: 我觉得随便
Katrina: I think it's fine.
Katrina:  就是我感觉会不会简单一点那种吗
Katrina: I just feel like it might be a bit simpler, right?
Tasha: 他说不要液体不要固体的啊
Tasha: He said no liquids, no solids, right?
Lucia: 啊，ok
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Katrina:  就是直接就像那种水牛奶一样的
Katrina: Just like, something like milk water.
Katrina:  因为我自己经常喝的糖水
Katrina: Because I often drink sweet water.
Katrina:  我看他们就是一点椰奶啊
Katrina: I see them using a bit of coconut milk.
Katrina:  然后芒果然后一些那个红豆
Katrina: Then some mango and some red beans.
Katrina:  就就这样配就很快
Katrina: Just mix it like that, it's quick.
Katrina:  嗯就是芋圆可能要熬一下
Katrina: Hmm, but you might need to cook the taro balls a bit.
Katrina:  椰果呢都能现买耶
Katrina: The coconut jelly can be bought ready-made.
Katrina:  随便看你看你吧
Katrina: Whatever, it's up to you.
Katrina:  你说什么就是什么
Katrina: Whatever you say goes.
Tasha: 你准备了芋圆
Tasha: You prepared taro balls?
Lucia: 大师来决定
Lucia: The master will decide.
Tasha: 芋圆我
Tasha: Taro balls, I...
Tasha: 我没有买芋圆材料
Tasha: I didn't buy the ingredients for taro balls.
Katrina:  芋圆是不是可以直接买
Katrina: Can't you just buy the taro balls?
Lucia: 芋圆也有成品吧
Lucia: They have ready-made taro balls, right?
Tasha: 嗯对
Tasha: Hmm, yeah.
Katrina: 直接买成品
Katrina: Just buy the ready-made ones.
Katrina:  那我看看
Katrina: Then I'll check it out.
Katrina:  4:20介绍完以后
Katrina: After introducing at 4:20
Katrina:  要有一个品尝甜品的时间
Katrina: We'll have a dessert tasting time.
Katrina:  那是不是要到4点
Katrina: So does it need to be at 4?
Katrina:  4:35开始
Katrina: Starting at 4:35.
Katrina:  但是我到5点多
Katrina: But I'll be there until around 5.
Katrina:  然后就开始吃晚饭晚饭
Katrina: Then we start dinner.
Katrina:  就是gas part之后我们就收眼镜传数据
Katrina: After the gas part, we'll collect the glasses and transfer the data.
Jake: 对对对然后吃饭就不录
Jake: Right, right, and we won't record dinner.
Jake: 吃饭不录
Jake: No recording dinner.
Alice: 那那晚饭是自己做吗
Alice: So, are we making dinner ourselves?
Katrina:  晚饭就那个点披萨嘛
Katrina: Dinner, we'll just order pizza.
Katrina:  然后一些烧烤
Katrina: And some barbecue.
Jake: 烧烤也不能录烧烤把
Jake: We can't record the barbecue either, right?
Jake: 眼镜给收
Jake: Collect the glasses.
Jake: 哦对
Jake: Oh, right.
Katrina:  没事刚好那那一个小时
Katrina: No problem, that hour is perfect.
Katrina:  那你就传数据第一个披萨得了
Katrina: Then you can transfer the data, and we get pizza first.
Jake: 对对barbecue
Jake: Yeah, yeah, barbecue.
Shure:  再说
Shure: Say it again.
Shure:  barbecue可以咱们咱们这两天自个吃
Shure: We can just have barbecue ourselves in the next couple of days.
Jake: 哈哈哈什么东西
Jake: Hahaha, what are you talking about?
Jake: 芭比q自己试试
Jake: Try barbecuing yourself.
Alice: 那个是烧烤炉吗
Alice: Is that a grill?
Jake: 是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Alice: 哦还挺大
Alice: Oh, it's quite big.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure:  然后人太多的话
Shure: If there are too many people...
Shure:  芭比q真的不好不好玩
Shure: Barbecuing isn't fun at all.
Alice: 特别慢对
Alice: It's especially slow, right.
Jake: 那就不要芭比q
Jake: Then let's not barbecue.
Jake: 没关系或者给他整两串得了
Jake: No worries, or we can just make a few skewers for him.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 意思意思
Lucia: Just for show.
Jake: 那就是意思
Jake: Exactly.
Jake: 哈哈哈那是我自己烤的
Jake: Hahaha, I grilled it myself.
Lucia: 点到点进来然后就到时候拿出去
Lucia: Just bring it in and take it out when the time comes.
Lucia: 说是烤的
Lucia: Say it's grilled.
Shure:  对菜咱们只买菜然后热一下
Shure: Yeah, let's just buy the food and heat it up.
Shure:  哇哈哈哈好
Shure: Hahaha, good idea.
Jake:妙啊
Jake: Brilliant.
Jake: 哈哈挺好看的
Jake: Haha, it looks great.
Lucia: 那还有西餐厅那种圆的那样罩住
Lucia: And we can use that round cover from western restaurants.
Lucia: 要不然话
Lucia: Otherwise...
Lucia: 大家就会发现
Lucia: Everyone will find out.
Lucia: 你这个拿出来的时候
Lucia: When you take it out...
Lucia: 就已经是烤好的了哦
Lucia: It's already grilled, right?
Lucia: 然后就这样挡一下
Lucia: Just cover it like this.
Lucia: 然后放在炉上烤一烤
Lucia: And grill it a bit on the stove.
Lucia: 说是刚烤的
Lucia: Say it's freshly grilled.
Lucia: 哈哈哈是是是
Lucia: Hahaha, exactly.
Shure:  太天才了
Shure: Genius.
Jake: 我们对一分钟考好
Jake: We'll grill it in a minute.
Katrina:  那就我们的那个活动就6点半到8点
Katrina: Our event will be from 6:30 to 8:00.
Katrina:  节目唱唱歌跳舞
Katrina: Singing and dancing.
Katrina:  一个半小时够了再长弄不下去了
Katrina: One and a half hours is enough, we can't do longer.
Katrina:  free time对大家可以表演一个半小时
Katrina: Free time, everyone can perform for one and a half hours.
Shure:  然后我们可以auction拆出来也行
Shure: Then we can have an auction, if some people haven't finished.
Shure:  就是比如说没进行完有的人没拍
Shure: For example, if someone hasn't bid.
Shure:  拍完然后啊可以继续想分享
Shure: After filming, we can continue sharing.
Lucia: 对大家自由交换
Lucia: Yes, everyone can freely exchange ideas.
Jake:也行也行
Jake: That's fine, that's fine.
Lucia: 嗯反正一般等家务已经有了
Lucia: Yeah, anyway, once the chores are done...
Katrina:  那就是5点半开饭然后6点半
Katrina: So, dinner starts at 5:30 and then at 6:30...
Tasha: 我要走了
Tasha: I have to go.
Tasha: 钱没花完怎么办
Tasha: What if I don't spend all the money?
Jake: 什么什么钱没花完
Jake: What? What money unspent?
Shure:  就是那个硬币啊
Shure: It's the coins, you know.
Jake: 硬币在我们要空掉那个通货
Jake: The coins, we need to use up that currency.
Jake: 对对对送俩充电宝吧
Jake: Yes, yes, give away two power banks.
Jake: 要不
Jake: Or...
Katrina: 送点充电宝
Katrina: Give away some power banks.
Tasha: 这挺好的
Tasha: That's pretty good.
Katrina:  还可以确实这个反正最后一天了
Katrina: Yeah, we can do that, it's the last day anyway.
Katrina:  你是不是也不太
Katrina: Are you also...
Jake: 是的是的抽奖环节
Jake: Yes, yes, the raffle segment.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我到时候也可以买一个
Lucia: Hahaha, I can buy one then.
Tasha: 晚会晚会都送充电宝
Tasha: At the party, everyone gets a power bank.
Lucia: 我们也是
Lucia: Us too.
Lucia: 我们招聘会也会送充电宝
Lucia: We give away power banks at our job fair too.
Jake: 哦原因找到了是吧
Jake: Oh, so that's the reason, huh?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina:  可以那就把充电宝送出去
Katrina: Fine, let's just give away the power banks.
Tasha: 只要来就可以送一个充电宝
Tasha: Anyone who comes gets a power bank.
Katrina:  看他们手上有
Katrina: Look, they have them in their hands.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure:  没有没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no, no.
Shure:  没有插上
Shure: Didn't plug it in.
Shure:  嗯好这回插上
Shure: Okay, this time it's plugged in.
Lucia: 哎我摸摸我这边
Lucia: Let me check mine.
Jake: 哎呀你这个没电了
Jake: Oh no, yours is out of power.
Jake: 已经没了
Jake: It's already dead.
Jake: 你这已经断掉了啊
Jake: It's already disconnected.
Jake: 对重新录一下
Jake: Yes, let's record again.
Shure:  对你你得
Shure: Yes, you need to...
Jake: 没关系就是我们重新看一遍时间就行
Jake: It's okay, we just need to check the time again.
Tasha: 我的亮吗
Tasha: Is mine on?
Lucia: 它亮着呢
Lucia: It's on.
Jake: 你再重新开一下
Jake: Try turning it on again.
Shure:  素材丢失
Shure: The footage is missing.
Jake: 稍有丢失问题不大
Jake: A little loss is not a big deal.
Katrina:  那你你的那part的东西买了吗
Katrina: So, did you buy your part of the stuff?
Lucia: 我们取决于我们要做什么
Lucia: It depends on what we're making.
Lucia: 我要买水母
Lucia: I want to buy jellyfish.
Lucia: 不是如果要买
Lucia: I mean, if we need to buy them.
Lucia: 如果要做水母灯的话
Lucia: If we are making jellyfish lamps.
Lucia: 大家是想用材料包做还是
Lucia: Do you want to use a kit or
Lucia: 就是那种循环利用的做
Lucia: something more recyclable?
Katrina:  什么叫循环利用的做
Katrina: What do you mean by recyclable?
Lucia: 就是拿那个
Lucia: Like using
Lucia: 呃叫什么奶茶盖那种
Lucia: um, what's it called, milk tea lids.
Lucia: 虽然奶茶盖其实我也没做过
Lucia: Though I haven't made it with milk tea lids before.
Lucia: 我之前做过材料包
Lucia: I used kits before.
Katrina:  奶茶盖的话那是不是得买奶茶呀
Katrina: If we use milk tea lids, don't we need to buy milk tea?
Lucia: 确实啊我们可以买个奶茶盖哦
Lucia: Exactly, we can buy some milk tea lids.
Jake: 好没问题
Jake: Sure, no problem.
Lucia: 然后它其实材料还蛮简单的
Lucia: The materials are actually quite simple.
Lucia: 就丝带和串珠这些就行
Lucia: Just ribbons and some beads.
Katrina:  那可以直接买材料包了
Katrina: Then we can just buy a kit.
Lucia: 买材料包的话好像就没有那种
Lucia: If we buy a kit, it won't really be
Katrina: 环保的
Katrina: Eco-friendly.
Lucia: 对特别环保的概念体现
Lucia: Yeah, it won't have that eco-friendly vibe.
Katrina:  那就那就得喝奶茶了哈哈
Katrina: Then we need to drink milk tea, haha.
Lucia: 或者也可以
Lucia: Or we can
Lucia: 应该应该
Lucia: Maybe, maybe
Lucia: 淘宝上有那种包装
Lucia: find those packages on Taobao.
Lucia: 也可以买一个我看看咋们这有没有
Lucia: We can buy one, let me check if they have it here.
Katrina:  但是你买包装跟买材料包感觉差不多
Katrina: But buying packages is almost the same as buying a kit.
Katrina:  意思
Katrina: I mean.
Lucia: 确实
Lucia: True.
Lucia: 但是就是
Lucia: But at least
Lucia: 至少它给人的视觉效果是环保的
Lucia: it gives an eco-friendly visual effect.
Lucia: 至于它流
Lucia: As for the process,
Lucia: 程中这个就我们自行控制
Lucia: we can control that ourselves.
Katrina:  那应该没啥问题了
Katrina: Then it should be fine.
Katrina:  然后可能嗯
Katrina: And maybe, hmm
Katrina:  如果要唱歌那种音响话筒这音调节
Katrina: If we want to sing, we'll need a sound system and a microphone, and adjust the audio.
Jake: 我们之前让GPT出了几个plan
Jake: We had GPT come up with a few plans before.
Jake: 嗯嗯嗯
Jake: Hmm, hmm, hmm.
Shure:  比如
Shure: For example?
Jake:环保版
Jake: An eco-friendly version.
Jake: 你你说你画我猜
Jake: Like a "you draw, I guess" game.
Katrina:  啊这个是参与者
Katrina: Ah, this is for the participants.
Katrina:  可以设置
Katrina: It can be set up.
Jake:参与者分组
Jake: Participants are grouped.
Jake: 每组选择一个环保词汇
Jake: Each group chooses an eco-friendly word.
Jake: 如太阳能
Jake: Like solar energy.
Jake: 拎废弃
Jake: Or waste collection.
Jake: 啊还可以吧
Jake: Ah, that could work.
Lucia: 这个也很不错
Lucia: This is also pretty good.
Tasha: 该怎么表达
Tasha: How should it be expressed?
Shure:  就是这种特别抽象的
Shure: It's something very abstract.
Shure:  然后大家就不好画
Shure: So it's hard for everyone to draw.
Lucia: 只能画吗
Lucia: Can we only draw?
Lucia: 不能描述吗
Lucia: Can't we describe it?
Jake: 画画
Jake: Draw.
Jake: 对啊不能说话了
Jake: Yeah, no talking allowed.
Lucia: OK
Lucia: OK.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina:  那就设置在晚上吧
Katrina: Then let's set it up for the evening.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Sure.
Katrina:  下午的时间不是很多
Katrina: There's not much time in the afternoon.
Katrina:  下午3点开始到5点半
Katrina: Starting from 3 PM to 5:30 PM.
Katrina:  就两个半小时
Katrina: Just two and a half hours.
Katrina:  介绍介绍
Katrina: To introduce and look around.
Katrina:  逛一逛就差不多了
Katrina: That should be enough.
Jake: 嗯还有一个更离谱的
Jake: Hmm, there's an even crazier one.
Jake: 他的Gtp确实厉害
Jake: Its GDP is really impressive.
Jake: 在沙盘或沙地中
Jake: In a sandbox or on sandy ground.
Jake: 隐藏一些微型塑料颗粒
Jake: Hide some tiny plastic particles.
Jake: 参与者使用镊子和放大镜
Jake: Participants use tweezers and magnifying glasses.
Jake: 在规定时间内
Jake: Within the given time.
Jake: 尽可能找出这些塑料颗粒
Jake: Try to find as many plastic particles as possible.
Jake: 哈哈这个游戏
Jake: Haha, this game.
Jake: 这个游戏
Jake: This game.
Jake: 可以让大家直观的认识到
Jake: Can help everyone realize directly.
Jake: 微塑料污染的隐蔽性
Jake: The insidious nature of microplastic pollution
Jake: 哈哈哈很妙这个游戏
Jake: Hahaha, this game is really fun.
Jake: 这个GPT就是使唤人
Jake: This GPT is really good at bossing people around.
Jake: ai使唤人挺能整
Jake: AI bossing people around is quite something.
Jake: 完了你可不能像他学
Jake: But you shouldn't learn from it.
Lucia: 感觉是一种变相的寻宝
Lucia: Feels like a form of treasure hunting.
Shure:  听没听到
Shure: Did you hear that?
Lucia: 寻废品对
Lucia: Yeah, scavenger hunting.
Jake: 你这个头发还是遮住了
Jake: Your hair is still covering it.
Jake: 要不还是我们
Jake: How about we...
Jake: 我们下午下午采购一波
Jake: We go shopping this afternoon.
Shure:  对采购一波
Shure: Yeah, let's go shopping.
Jake: 采购一波
Jake: Go shopping.
Katrina:  对下午要去采购是吗
Katrina: So, we're going shopping this afternoon, right?
Tasha: 嗯这个吗
Tasha: Yeah, this one?
Shure:  对就是这种个人
Shure: Yeah, just like that.
Shure:  这种小别的那种
Shure: Those small ones.
Jake: 我们再看一圈吧
Jake: Let's take another look around.
Jake: 我们其实不用
Jake: We actually don't need...
Jake: 但是也看一眼
Jake: But let's take a look anyway.
Lucia:呃停住了
Lucia: Uh, it stopped.
Jake: 哎呀完了
Jake: Oh no, it's over.
Jake: 没事
Jake: It's okay.
Jake: 我们其实剩下的一个人就行
Jake: We actually just need one person left.
Jake: 但是就转一圈比较稳妥
Jake: But it's safer to take another round.
Katrina:  我发现这名片好好看
Katrina: I found this business card looks really nice.
Shure:  哦你们看那个你想活出怎样的人生
Shure: Oh, did you guys watch "How Do You Live Your Life"?
Shure:  关崎骏那个
Shure: The one by Hayao Miyazaki.
Katrina:  看没看懂
Katrina: Did you understand it?
Katrina:  后来看解析
Katrina: I watched the analysis later.
Katrina:  了回来看解析
Katrina: Should've watched the analysis first.
Katrina:  应该先看解析再去看
Katrina: Then watched the movie.
Shure:  那些数字
Shure: Those numbers...
Alice: 他只有5%的电正充着电
Alice: He's only got 5% battery, charging now.
Alice: 他不会充的没用的快吧
Alice: It won't charge fast enough, right?
Jake: 呃不会不会不会不会
Jake: Uh, no, no, no, it won't.
Shure:  只要抱着太紧了就可以
Shure: As long as you hold it tight enough.
Katrina:  对OK那这就差不多敲定了是吧
Katrina: Yeah, okay, so it's pretty much settled then, right?
Jake: 差不多了那我们看看要准备什么吧
Jake: Yeah, pretty much. Let's see what we need to prepare.
Jake: 这几
Jake: These few...
Katrina:  嗯我想想啊就是各自买各自的材料
Katrina: Hmm, let me think, we should each buy our own materials.
Katrina:  然后
Katrina: And then...
Katrina:  然后要有音响和话筒如果要唱歌的话
Katrina: And then we need speakers and a microphone if we're going to sing.
Shure:  这个我都能搞定
Shure: I can handle all of that.
Jake: 例外啊你本来就乐队的是吧
Jake: Makes sense, you're already in a band, right?
Katrina:  啊你可以把音乐队都给弄来
Katrina: Ah, you can bring the whole band.
Katrina:  我们当时就也总是那乐队同学带音响
Katrina: Back then, our bandmates would always bring the sound system.
Shure:  这这算商演吧应该
Shure: This feels like a commercial performance, right?
Katrina:  商演商演商演
Katrina: Commercial, commercial, commercial.
Jake: 学术商演学术商演学术商演
Jake: Academic commercial performance, academic commercial performance, academic commercial performance.
Jake: 在学术会议上面商演演唱会算什么呀
Jake: What's a concert at an academic conference anyway?
Jake: 你们接过这种活吗
Jake: Have you ever taken such gigs?
Shure:  之前邀邀请过但是哦没没去
Shure: We've been invited before, but oh, we didn't go.
Shure:  没去有点太尴尬了主要是
Shure: Didn't go, it was too awkward, mainly.
Jake: 哦这下面人在看pose呢
Jake: Oh, the audience is watching the poses.
Jake: 然后你在这瞅我
Jake: And you're just staring at me.
Shure:  对对啊多尬呀我靠
Shure: Yeah, yeah, how awkward is that, geez.
Katrina:  他那个呃你们买了什么
Katrina: So, what did you guys buy?
Katrina:  支架和小桌子吗
Katrina: Stands and small tables?
Jake: 嗯我们要不看看快递
Jake: Hmm, why don't we check the deliveries?
Jake: 或者我们到处看一看吧
Jake: Or let's look around.
Jake: 我们
Jake: We...
Jake: 因为这个房间我们可能也要收拾收拾
Jake: Because we might need to tidy up this room.
Jake: 装饰装饰
Jake: Decorate it.
Jake: 哦这个那我们是不是
Jake: Oh, should we...
Katrina:  如果你要世界地球日为主题
Katrina: If you want a World Earth Day theme...
Katrina:  要买一点贴画呀
Katrina: We need to buy some stickers.
Jake: 对对对是的
Jake: Yes, yes, exactly.
Jake: 但是这个墙不能贴
Jake: But we can't stick them on the wall.
Jake: 我们也得想想办法怎么搞
Jake: We need to figure out a way.
Katrina:  有那种无痕贴的挂钩就是他就不
Katrina: There are those hook stickers that leave no marks.
Jake: 不能贴这种墙
Jake: Can't stick on this wall.
Katrina:  我知道
Katrina: I know.
Katrina:  我姐结婚的时候他们就是那种贴的
Katrina: My sister used them for her wedding.
Katrina:  就是酒店贴的
Katrina: They used them at the hotel.
Katrina:  可以撕下来就完全无痕的
Katrina: You can peel them off without any marks.
Jake: OK如果很稳妥的话可以不然的话赔钱
Jake: OK, if it's really reliable, otherwise, we pay for damages.
Jake: 哈哈哈对这样砍了
Jake: Hahaha, right, just cut it off.
Katrina:  然后还有就是我们每个人的东西的话
Katrina: And also, each of us needs to bring our own stuff.
Katrina:  他的甜品有自己的甜品家
Katrina: His dessert has its own dessert house.
Katrina:  那我们每个人
Katrina: So each of us...
Katrina:  东西是不是也要有装桌子摆摊
Katrina: Do we all need to have stuff to set up a table for the stall?
Jake: 嗯可以
Jake: Hmm, that's possible.
Katrina:  因为那天呃
Katrina: Because that day, uh...
Shure: 去宜家采购一波吧
Shure: Let's go shopping at IKEA.
Katrina:  20多人哈哈哈
Katrina: Over 20 people, haha.
Jake: 过分了
Jake: That's too much.
Katrina: 直接给别墅主人贴新家具
Katrina: Directly giving the villa owner new furniture.
Alice: 对啊一个够吗
Alice: Yeah, is one enough?
Alice: 还是要多买两个
Alice: Or should we buy two more?
Katrina:  你这一个是就是多少人可以一起玩
Katrina: How many people can play with just one?
Shure:  大概就一个人一起玩
Shure: About one person can play.
Lucia: 哈哈哈两三个应该也行
Lucia: Haha, two or three should be fine too.
Lucia: 再多
Lucia: Any more...
Shure: 其实买3个差不多
Shure: Actually, buying three should be enough.
Jake: 我们要不玩一下
Jake: Why don't we play a bit?
Jake: 怎么玩对对对
Jake: How to play, yeah, yeah.
Lucia:咱们 我们先来试验一下
Lucia: Let's test it out first.
Shure:  我们这些这些都得试验一遍
Shure: We need to test all of these.
Shure:  就是甜品我们得先先吃一遍
Shure: Like, we need to try all the desserts first.
Shure:  然后烧烤也得先吃一遍
Shure: And the barbecue, we need to try that too.
Lucia: 算盘打的
Lucia: You're really calculating.
Alice: 这是一个支架的就不用管它
Alice: This is just a stand, we don't need to worry about it.
Shure:  毕竟其实这个比点外卖会便宜一些
Shure: After all, this is actually cheaper than ordering takeout.
Tasha: 什么会比点外卖便宜
Tasha: What is cheaper than ordering takeout?
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What?
Shure:  就是比如说自己搞顿烧烤
Shure: Like, for example, making our own barbecue.
Shure:  比点一桌子这样的烤串肯定会便宜
Shure: It's definitely cheaper than ordering a table full of skewers.
Jake: 嗯那是这烧烤卖的可贵了
Jake: Yeah, that's true. Barbecue is quite expensive.
Shure:  一个是一串四五块钱哦
Shure: One skewer is four or five bucks.
Alice: 啪挺多
Alice: That's quite a lot.
Jake: 哦看起来很难拼到吧
Jake: Oh, it looks hard to assemble, right?
Lucia: 哇，好可爱耶
Lucia: Wow, it's so cute.
Alice: 确实不太好拼比较费时间
Alice: It's really not easy to assemble, takes a lot of time.
Tasha: 要怎么拼
Tasha: How to assemble it?
Jake: 就把它给拼成一个圆啊
Jake: Just put it together into a circle.
Jake: 你要fit进去边缘
Jake: You need to fit it around the edges.
Shure:  这种弧形的都应该在边边
Shure: These curved pieces should all go on the edges.
Jake: 他有可能骗你的吧
Jake: He might be tricking you.
Jake: 有会有可能吧
Jake: It's possible.
Tasha: 哎你这个明显就不在边边你这个
Tasha: Hey, this one is obviously not on the edge.
Tasha: 不对
Tasha: No, it's not right.
Jake: 毫无头绪
Jake: No clue at all.
Jake: 一个都找到
Jake: Can't find a single one.
Lucia: 这个应该是在边边的这个这个部分
Lucia: This should be on the edge, this part here.
Shure:  这个某一个边
Shure: This is one of the edges.
Jake: 对一个边是在边边的
Jake: Yes, one edge is on the side.
Lucia: 这个好像也能贴住
Lucia: This one also seems to fit.
Shure:  这不完全
Shure: This isn't complete.
Lucia: 不完全OK
Lucia: Not completely, okay.
Jake: 他是一定会完全还是他他就会
Jake: Is it supposed to be completely or just...
Katrina:  这个很适合放在安全性那边
Katrina: This is perfect for the security section.
Katrina:  让大家熟悉起来哦
Katrina: To get everyone familiar with it.
Katrina:  这几个人坐在一起
Katrina: These people are sitting together.
Jake: 有那种特别大的玩一把
Jake: There's a big one to play with.
Lucia: 这个看起来比较园
Lucia: This one looks more round.
Katrina:  就是没有很大的就是很有可能这样
Katrina: It's not that big, it's very likely like this.
Lucia: 很有可能
Lucia: Very likely.
Shure:  哎呦是吧
Shure: Oh, really?
Shure:  屌的嘞哈哈哈
Shure: That's awesome, hahaha.
Lucia: 感觉应该是看起来很
Lucia: It seems to fit very well.
Lucia: 就是密合程度是比较高的嗯
Lucia: The degree of tightness is quite high.
Lucia: 那这个就是哎有可能
Lucia: So, this one is... might be possible.
Tasha: 天才三位天才
Tasha: Geniuses, three geniuses.
Shure: 洒洒水啊
Shure: Piece of cake.
Shure:  这不两分钟搞定啊哈哈哈
Shure: We can finish this in two minutes, hahaha.
Lucia: 这里是缺一个什么呢
Lucia: What's missing here?
Shure: 谁的脚比较啊
Shure: Whose foot fits better?
Alice: 哦不是完全拼合的
Alice: Oh, it's not completely fitting.
Alice: 还是有一点点缝缝的
Alice: There's still a bit of a gap.
Alice: 哦不对看一下答案吗
Alice: Oh, no, should we look at the answer?
Shure:  不需要不需要
Shure: No need, no need.
Alice:就是你也记不住啊
Alice: You won't remember it anyway.
Jake: 没有没有我们能拼出来
Jake: No, no, we can figure it out.
Jake: 能拼出来
Jake: We can figure it out.
Shure:  哈哈哈我们看答案
Shure: Hahaha, we'll check the answer?
Shure:  开什么玩笑
Shure: Are you kidding?
Lucia: 哈哈我觉得这个
Lucia: Haha, I think this...
Lucia: 这个游戏参与度还是很高的
Lucia: This game has a high participation rate.
Alice: 反正你也记不住
Alice: You won't remember it anyway.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 有可能这个呢
Lucia: Maybe it's this one
Tasha: 我刚刚看到了跟他很像的在这里嗯
Tasha: I just saw something that looks like it here
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm
Katrina:  切不进去
Katrina: Can't cut through it
Lucia: 差一点点
Lucia: Almost there
Jake: 嗯怎么一个靠谱的都找不到呢
Jake: Hmm, why can't we find a reliable one?
Jake: 哈哈哈这算吗
Jake: Hahaha, does this count?
Jake: 这个
Jake: This one
Lucia: 这俩看起来不是颜色合缝
Lucia: These two don't seem to match in color
Lucia: 这是是一块的吗
Lucia: Are these pieces from the same set?
Jake: 对他不是颜色合缝
Jake: Yeah, the colors don't match
Katrina:  但是如果颜色合缝就很好找啊
Katrina: But if the colors match, it would be easy to find
Katrina:  找那个不同的
Katrina: Find the different one
Jake:他有可能有很多解法
Jake: There might be many solutions
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm
Jake: 毫无头绪
Jake: I'm completely lost
Jake: 这可能就啥也没有啊
Jake: There might be nothing here
Jake: 逗你玩哈哈哈
Jake: Just messing with you, hahaha
Tasha: 我觉得都没有一圈怎么回事
Tasha: I feel like there's not a complete loop, what's going on?
Jake: 对啊他面积都不够啊
Jake: Yeah, the area isn't enough
Jake: 对我们要不直接往里面放吧
Jake: Let's just put it in directly
Jake: 你看能不能完了
Jake: See if we can finish it
Shure:  哈哈哈急了有人急了
Shure: Hahaha, someone's getting anxious
Lucia: 哈哈哈有人急了
Lucia: Hahaha, someone's getting anxious
Jake: 哈哈哈不是不是不是不是
Jake: Hahaha, no, no, no
Jake: 往里面放看看
Jake: Try putting it in
Lucia: 面积可能是差不多的吧
Lucia: The area might be about right
Lucia: 看起来就是
Lucia: It looks like it
Lucia: 这还有一些就感觉可能是差不多的
Lucia: There are some pieces that feel like they might be right
Lucia: 哎这是猫头鹰
Lucia: Oh, it's an owl
Lucia: 好可爱哦
Lucia: So cute
Shure:  有人急了呀
Shure: Someone's getting anxious
Alice: 这样看起来几个人一起玩也可以
Alice: Looks like a few people can play together
Jake: 是的是的挺好的这个东西
Jake: Yes, yes, this is pretty good
Shure:  这也不是颜色盒
Shure: This one doesn't match either
Lucia: 好难哦
Lucia: So hard
Jake: 是什么东西
Jake: What is this?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 是小老鼠吗
Lucia: Is it a little mouse?
Lucia: 青蛙
Lucia: The frog land god has a point.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Shure: 咱们是野生动物
Shure: We're wild animals.
Shure:  不是神话故事
Shure: Not mythological stories.
Shure:  还土地公公
Shure: And land god.
Jake: 野生神仙
Jake: Wild immortals, wild.
Katrina:  特别像一个表情包
Katrina: Looks like an emoji.
Jake: 没有
Jake: No.
Alice:怎么又不亮了
Alice: Why is it not lighting up again?
Jake: 我看一下是
Jake: Let me take a look.
Shure: 那边没插上
Shure: It's not plugged in over there.
Lucia: 这个也不是啊
Lucia: This isn't it either.
Lucia: 奇怪
Lucia: Weird.
Alice: 但是他一直
Alice: But it's always
Alice: 是35的电
Alice: 35% charged.
Lucia: 不好意思
Lucia: Sorry.
Alice: 就没有嗯
Alice: So there's no, uh...
Katrina:  我也是一直35
Katrina: Mine is always 35% too.
Jake: 对他电很多
Jake: Yeah, it has a lot of power.
Lucia: 嗯不是
Lucia: No, that's not it.
Shure:  他是一个2万毫安
Shure: It's a 20,000 mAh battery.
Jake: 是我看一下你的这个APP
Jake: Let me check your app.
Tasha: 我觉得这个是这样子
Tasha: I think this is how it works.
Katrina:  就是那软件吗对
Katrina: Is it that software? Yes.
Tasha: 这个是不是这样子
Tasha: Is this how it works?
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Jake: 差距差距就对了
Jake: The difference, the difference, that's it.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 我看一下看一下
Jake: Let me see, let me see.
Lucia: 嗯，这个好像不对
Lucia: Hmm, this doesn't seem right.
Lucia: 这个能和她放一起
Lucia: Can this be placed together with hers?
Jake: 灯坏了呵呵呵
Jake: The light is broken, haha.
Alice: 他在录但是
Alice: It's recording but...
Lucia: 他是就是是不是自动
Lucia: Is it automatic?
Lucia: 自动监测
Lucia: Automatic detection?
Lucia: 觉得现在这个环境不需要开灯
Lucia: It thinks the current environment doesn't need light.
Jake: 没有不是不是不是这个
Jake: No, no, no, that's not it.
Jake: 这个是为了保护被拍摄人的隐私啊
Jake: This is to protect the privacy of the person being filmed.
Jake: 被拍摄人知道自己
Jake: The person being filmed knows...
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 哦OK
Lucia: Oh, OK.
Jake: 但是其实拍摄人不知道
Jake: But actually, the cameraman doesn't know.
Jake: 但是呵呵
Jake: But haha.
Jake: 拍摄人应该会感觉到吧
Jake: The cameraman should be able to feel it, right?
Lucia:  啊了胜于无对
Lucia: Better than nothing, right?
Jake: 再输一下
Jake: Do it again.
Jake: 他
Jake: He...
Jake: 刚刚其实是软件没有更新你的状态
Jake: Actually, the software didn't update your status.
Jake: 所以你是没有在录
Jake: So you weren't recording.
Jake: 但是软件上也是我在录
Jake: But on the software, it showed that I was recording.
Jake: 所以这
Jake: So this...
Lucia: 个到底是什么
Lucia: What exactly is this?
Lucia: 还有5个角哎
Lucia: It has five corners!
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Mm-hmm, right.
Jake: 你按照现在的事情
Jake: Based on the current situation...
Lucia: 神奇
Lucia: Interesting.
Shure: 就是蛤蟆这个
Shure: It's like a toad.
Jake: 哈哈哈估计最后才能放吧
Jake: Haha, it might be shown at the end.
Jake: 这是大嘴鸟是吧
Jake: Is this a toucan?
Tasha: 哦我靠
Tasha: Oh my god.
Lucia: 好抽象啊
Lucia: So abstract.
Jake: 大嘴鸟
Jake: Toucan.
Jake: 这个也很抽象
Jake: This is also very abstract.
Jake: 谁家牛长这样
Jake: Whose cow looks like this?
Shure:  野牛啊水牛
Shure: Wild ox, water buffalo.
Jake: 那水牛为什么下面会长稻草
Jake: Then why does the water buffalo have straw underneath?
Alice: 他站在草上
Alice: It's standing on grass.
Lucia: 好难哦
Lucia: So difficult.
Shure:  毛很长
Shure: The fur is long.
Lucia: 这个这个
Lucia: This, this...
Lucia: 是不是他这一边
Lucia: Is it on this side?
Lucia: 是还是这里的
Lucia: Or is it here?
Shure:  他叫牦牛
Shure: It's a yak.
Jake: 对这个很妙
Jake: Yeah, this is interesting.
Jake: 嗯这个太妙了
Jake: Mm, this is really interesting.
Lucia: 然后既然是这一边的话
Lucia: And since it's on this side...
Lucia: 那这里应该有一个能放的东西会是这个吗
Lucia: Shouldn't there be something to place here, like this?
Alice: 尖尖的
Alice: Pointy.
Lucia: 好像不是耶
Lucia: Seems like it's not.
Lucia: 不是呢
Lucia: It's not.
Shure: CPU白烧了
Shure: The CPU burned out for nothing.
Shure:  AI快给我一个解法
Shure: AI, quickly give me a solution.
Jake: 大家一直在看时间
Jake: Everyone's been watching the time.
Jake: 看秒表这个数据
Jake: Watching the stopwatch data.
Katrina:  看这个书为了干啥
Katrina: What's the point of reading this book?
Jake: 为了同步
Jake: For synchronization.
Jake: 回头就是在某一个帧上面把时间写上
Jake: Later, we'll write the time on a specific frame.
Katrina:  哦明白了
Katrina: Oh, got it.
Jake: 哎
Jake: Hey.
Lucia: 好难哦
Lucia: This is so difficult.
Jake: 这个会在边上吗
Jake: Will this be on the side?
Jake: 还有没有边了
Jake: Is there any edge left?
Lucia: 这个边怎么给人一种不太够的感觉
Lucia: Why does this edge feel insufficient?
Alice: 他这不是颜色和风
Alice: It's not the color and style.
Alice: 有的是差不多的那种
Alice: Some of them are quite similar.
Alice: 嗯这回是比较不太像
Alice: Hmm, this time it doesn't really look alike.
Jake: 要不还是全放进去吧
Jake: How about we just put everything in?
Jake: 哈哈全放进去
Jake: Haha, put it all in.
Jake: 先看一看他乱拼的话差多少
Jake: Let's first see how much difference it makes if he messes up the pieces.
Tasha: 这只鸟好占位
Tasha: This bird takes up so much space.
Katrina:  所有的都可以放进去
Katrina: We can put everything in.
Alice: 对
Alice: Yes.
Jake: 刚刚就是这么拿出来的
Jake: We just took it out like this.
Shure:  比那个不是大只的哦
Shure: It's not bigger than that one.
Tasha: 那就塞个你
Tasha: Then just stuff you in.
Tasha: 你塞不进去换一个
Tasha: If you can't fit, try another one.
Tasha: 你也塞不进去
Tasha: You can't fit either.
Katrina:  我们塞他
Katrina: We'll stuff him.
Tasha: 这啥这是刺猬吗
Tasha: What's this, a hedgehog?
Alice: 哈哈可以
Alice: Haha, that works.
Alice: 他肯定就在这了
Alice: He's definitely here.
Lucia: 哦这是刺猬我以为他是太阳
Lucia: Oh, it's a hedgehog, I thought it was the sun.
Alice:呃的胯下
Alice: Uh, under his crotch.
Lucia: 看哈哈哈像不像太阳
Lucia: Look, haha, doesn't it look like the sun?
Shure: 流氓
Shure: Pervert.
Lucia: 我觉得这个太阳应该很好找到对应的
Lucia: I think this sun should be easy to match.
Lucia: 就因为他这里有很多的刺
Lucia: Because it has a lot of spikes here.
Lucia: 所以我觉得这个是这个特别像耶
Lucia: So I think this part looks very similar.
Jake: 哇这个这个太严格了吧
Jake: Wow, this is too strict.
Jake: 耶我去
Jake: Geez, come on.
Jake: 这太严格了
Jake: This is too strict.
Jake: 如果都是这种严格程度的话
Jake: If everything is this strict,
Alice: 那就好找了
Alice: Then it will be easy to find.
Lucia: 胜利又顺利找到一个
Lucia: Victory! Found another one smoothly.
Alice: 谁没加
Alice: Who hasn't added?
Shure:  如今你四海为家
Shure: Now you're at home wherever you go.
Tasha: 怎么办还有这么多人没有家
Tasha: What to do, so many people still don't have a home.
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Alright.
Shure:  回家回回家
Shure: Go home, go home.
Shure:  回家是最好的礼物
Shure: Going home is the best gift.
Jake: 放BGM吧
Jake: Play the BGM.
Jake: 要不BGM再继续进去
Jake: Or we can continue with the BGM.
Shure:  这时候应该放这个
Shure: We should play this now.
Tasha: 怎么办
Tasha: What to do?
Lucia: 这是不是可以把这些标注一下
Lucia: Should we mark these?
Alice: 为什么这时候要放这个
Alice: Why play this now?
Alice: 好像真的是在这的
Alice: It seems like it fits here.
Tasha: 嗯是吧
Tasha: Hmm, right?
Jake: 嗯很难很难说
Jake: Hmm, it's hard to say.
Jake: 好吧不是有可能
Jake: Well, it's possible.
Lucia: 能让AI把这些轮廓都扫描一下
Lucia: Can we let AI scan these outlines?
Lucia: 然后让他帮忙拼吗
Lucia: And then help us piece them together?
Lucia: 嗯试试
Lucia: Hmm, let's try.
Alice: 无限次试
Alice: Try infinitely.
Alice: 对反正他算的快
Alice: Yeah, it's fast anyway.
Lucia: 对就是应该有这种类似的软件吧
Lucia: Yeah, there should be some software for this, right?
Lucia: 不然就是那种乐高都是怎么设计的
Lucia: Otherwise, how do they design those Lego sets?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Alice: 动物世界
Alice: Animal World.
Tasha: 哈哈哈这个应该是这样子的吧
Tasha: Hahaha, it should be like this, right?
Tasha: 哈哈哈哎
Tasha: Hahaha, hey.
Lucia: 很像很像
Lucia: Very similar.
Lucia: 应该是的
Lucia: It should be.
Lucia: 嗯好厉害
Lucia: Hmm, impressive.
Tasha: 他们俩捆绑了
Tasha: They're tied together.
Lucia: 对就是把
Lucia: Yeah, just put
Lucia: 只要把那
Lucia: as long as
Lucia: 个能合上的都放在一起先
Lucia: you put the ones that can be combined together first.
Lucia: 然后再看他们具体是个怎么回事
Lucia: Then see what the deal is with them.
Tasha: 把不对的拿出来
Tasha: Take out the incorrect ones.
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Alice: 他俩是不是
Alice: Are those two...
Lucia: 这个肯定在边上
Lucia: This one should be on the side.
Lucia: 所以这个也可以这样放一下
Lucia: So this one can be placed like this.
Alice:他仨
Alice: The three of them...
Lucia: 但是这他这个这么明显
Lucia: But this one is so obvious.
Lucia: 应该会有一个
Lucia: There should be one.
Alice: 他俩像不像一家的感觉
Alice: Do these two seem like they belong together?
Alice: 是一家的
Alice: They are together.
Tasha: 他们俩像一家的
Tasha: They do look like they're together.
Tasha: 他就没有那么一家他
Tasha: This one doesn't seem to fit with the others.
Tasha: 这样子吧
Tasha: How about this?
Tasha: 中间能不能再塞一条东西
Tasha: Can we fit something in the middle?
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Lucia: 是不是有点像啊
Lucia: Doesn't this look a bit like it?
Jake: 反过来不至于
Jake: Turning it around doesn't seem necessary.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice: 或者在这里面谁是条条的
Alice: Or who among these is the strip?
Tasha: 他他不一定对
Tasha: He might not be right.
Tasha: 他拿走这这些小家伙都不对
Tasha: Taking these ones away is wrong.
Lucia: 这个有有谁是长成这样的
Lucia: Who looks like this?
Tasha: 这样吗
Tasha: Like this?
Shure: 还可以这个样子哦
Shure: It can also be like this.
Shure:  在中间留着一点
Shure: Leave a bit in the middle.
Shure:  然后这样哦
Shure: And then like this.
Lucia: 有道理就可以
Lucia: Makes sense, it works.
Lucia: 看这个和这两边感觉就比较哎
Lucia: Look, this and these two sides feel just right.
Tasha: 找刚刚找的那个呢
Tasha: What about the one we just found?
Tasha: 哦不是
Tasha: Oh, no.
Tasha: 我还找了一个呢
Tasha: I found another one.
Alice: 我把它拆了
Alice: I took it apart.
Alice: 拆成他俩了
Alice: Split it into two.
Alice: 就你刚刚说的是这个吧行哦
Alice: You mean this one, right? Okay.
Lucia: 哎这个有点像
Lucia: Hey, this one looks a bit like it.
Tasha: 他又在上去存疑
Tasha: He's going back to being doubtful again.
Lucia: 完了咱他俩这么长时间都没拼出来
Lucia: Oh no, we haven't been able to piece it together for so long.
Lucia: 要是放到下午大家拼可能也拼不出来
Lucia: If we leave it for the afternoon, no one might be able to piece it together.
Katrina:  让他们玩一下午吧对
Katrina: Let them play with it all afternoon, right.
Katrina:  这拼出来了给多少金币
Katrina: How many coins do we get if we piece it together?
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Alice: 这个为什么在摸他的屁股
Alice: Why is this guy touching his butt?
Alice: 然后这个蹲在他的屁股上
Alice: And then this one is squatting on his butt.
Tasha: 哈哈哈你是来拉屎的吧
Tasha: Hahaha, are you here to poop?
Alice: 哈哈哈真的是这样放的吗
Alice: Hahaha, is this really the way to place it?
Lucia: 哈哈也可能不是
Lucia: Haha, maybe not.
Shure:  这绝对不是
Shure: Definitely not.
Shure:  太变态了
Shure: That's too perverted.
Tasha: 好了只有目前这些是确定的
Tasha: Alright, this is all we know for now.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Alice: 他的这个脚肯定
Alice: This foot definitely...
Lucia: 这有可能
Lucia: It's possible.
Lucia: 吗不太可能
Lucia: But not very likely.
Shure:  这个脚肯定插到谁的屁股里
Shure: This foot is definitely going into someone's butt.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 这个在这的
Tasha: This one is here.
Alice: 他揭着他的屁股好
Alice: He's lifting his butt up.
Alice: 好尴尬
Alice: So awkward.
Tasha: 刚刚谁说他是土地公公的
Tasha: Who just said he is the Earth God?
Alice: 哎这两个是不是可以在一起哇
Alice: Hey, can these two be together?
Lucia: 好了哇
Lucia: Alright, sure.
Alice: 再来一个
Alice: One more.
Alice: 好厉害
Alice: Awesome.
Lucia: 感觉胜利在望了
Lucia: Feels like victory is in sight.
Tasha: 三人游戏
Tasha: Three-person game.
Jake: 三人游戏
Jake: Three-person game.
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: Okay, okay.
Jake: 这是个什么
Jake: What is this?
Lucia: 这是个猴子吧
Lucia: It's a monkey, right?
Lucia: 好像看起来好像
Lucia: Looks like it.
Jake:哦是的
Jake: Oh, yes.
Alice: 哎这样也挺挺搭的
Alice: Hey, this fits pretty well.
Jake: 像吗哎
Jake: Really?
Jake: 好像一般像吧
Jake: Looks so-so, right?
Tasha: 亚班吧
Tasha: Maybe.
Jake:有可能吧
Jake: Possibly.
Jake: 像吗一般像一般像
Jake: Does it look like it? Kind of, kind of.
Tasha: 两个细长条形的
Tasha: Two long, thin shapes.
Jake: 这片头多久啊
Jake: How long is this intro?
Jake: 几分钟刚刚的
Jake: Just a few minutes ago
Jake: 动物世界
Jake: Animal World
Shure: 4分32秒
Shure: 4 minutes and 32 seconds
Shure:  哈哈
Shure: Haha
Alice:什么东西
Alice: What is it?
Jake: 刚刚那个动物世界
Jake: Just now, that Animal World
Jake: 4分32秒已经悄悄的过去了
Jake: 4 minutes and 32 seconds have quietly passed
Tasha: 才过去4分钟吗
Tasha: Only 4 minutes have passed?
Tasha: 嗯哈哈
Tasha: Hmm haha
Jake: 还好还好
Jake: Not bad, not bad
Lucia: 怎么觉得这个弧形边完全找不全对
Lucia: Why does it feel like this curved edge can't be matched at all?
Tasha: 所以
Tasha: So
Tasha: 这个算是
Tasha: This is like
Katrina: 反了
Katrina: Reversed
Tasha: 是吧哎
Tasha: Right, oh
Katrina:  反了吧没反
Katrina: Reversed, right? No, not reversed
Alice: 嗯就这颜色
Alice: Hmm, just this color
Tasha: 我不想
Tasha: I don't want to
Tasha: 哎你刚不是把那个放在一起了吗
Tasha: Hey, didn't you just put that together?
Alice: 疑似
Alice: Suspected
Alice: 也不想
Alice: Don't want to either
Lucia: 他到底是哪一边
Lucia: Which side is it?
Alice: 他是来迷惑你的
Alice: It's here to confuse you
Lucia: 感觉两个好像都可以
Lucia: It feels like both could work
Tasha: 不太像这么大啊
Tasha: It doesn't seem that big
Shure:  血压高了怎么办
Shure: What to do if blood pressure goes up?
Lucia:  哎会是这样的
Lucia: Ah, it might be like this
Jake: 嗯嗯
Jake: Hmm hmm
Tasha: 这个是在这个边边上吗
Tasha: Is this on this edge?
Tasha: 这个是在边边上
Tasha: This is on the edge
Jake: 拆快递吧
Jake: Let's open the package
Jake: 要不哈哈
Jake: Otherwise, haha
Jake: 啊拆快递拆快递拆快递拆快递
Jake: Ah, let's open the package, open the package, open the package
Katrina:  我去把我的花不行了
Katrina: I'll go get my flower, it's wilting
Shure:  血压高了
Shure: Blood pressure is up
Alice: 怎么怎么回事
Alice: What's going on?
Lucia: 好难啊
Lucia: It's so hard
Jake: 拆拆一会回来
Jake: Open it, take a break, and come back
Jake: 呃呃就有灵感了
Jake: Uh, uh, then you'll have inspiration
Alice: 在哪拆快递
Alice: Where to open the packages?
Jake: 呃那边有一些快递
Jake: Uh, there are some packages over there.
Jake: 然后就过来拆
Jake: Then just come over and open them.
Katrina:  我要整一波我的
Katrina: I need to open my batch.
Katrina:  我还有在菜鸟驿站的
Katrina: I also have some at the delivery station.
Jake: 嗯哦我看一下他们
Jake: Hmm, oh, let me check them.
Lucia: 怎么会呢
Lucia: How could that be?
Alice: 他在边也
Alice: He's over there too.
Alice: 可以
Alice: Okay.
Lucia: 这个有没有一点
Lucia: Doesn't this look a bit...
Lucia: 有没有一点点像啊
Lucia: Doesn't it look a bit similar?
Alice:有可能
Alice: Maybe.
Lucia: 这个地方他偏平一点
Lucia: This part is a bit flatter.
Lucia: 这是不是一个相对平坦的一个表面
Lucia: Isn't this a relatively flat surface?
Lucia: 嗯不行显得太小
Lucia: Hmm, no, it seems too small.
Lucia: 有可能会是这样
Lucia: It could be like this.
Tasha: 啊不行啊这是太平了
Tasha: Ah no, this is too flat.
Tasha: 衣服湿了
Tasha: My clothes are wet.
Lucia: 一般相似先放在这里好了
Lucia: Let's just place the similar ones here first.
Tasha: 那把它按在这里面的哪里呢
Tasha: Then where should we put it in here?
Lucia: 哈哈哈好问题
Lucia: Haha, good question.
Lucia: 这个有可能吧
Lucia: Could it be here?
Lucia: 是不是也不太可能呀
Lucia: Or maybe not?
Lucia: 好迷惑啊我
Lucia: I'm so confused.
Lucia: 我小时候玩那个1,000块拼图
Lucia: When I was a kid, I used to play with 1,000-piece puzzles.
Lucia: 从来没有拼出来过
Lucia: I never completed them.
Tasha: 真的吗对我每次后面有数字
Tasha: Really? I always had numbers on the back.
Tasha: 啊是吗
Tasha: Oh, really?
Tasha: 是呀哎
Tasha: Yes, indeed.
Lucia: 那难道我买的是盗版的
Lucia: Did I buy a fake one then?
Lucia: 反正我就是
Lucia: Anyway, I...
Lucia: 我好不容易拼了其中的一部分
Lucia: I barely completed a part of it.
Lucia: 然后就不会拼了
Lucia: Then I couldn't continue.
Lucia: 然后我就放弃
Lucia: So I gave up.
Lucia: 好难呀
Lucia: It's so hard.
Alice:玩困了怎么办
Alice: What if you get tired of playing?
Alice: 怎么说呢这个应该催眠了
Alice: How to say, it could be quite hypnotic.
Tasha: 嗯喝杯咖啡喝
Tasha: Hmm, have a cup of coffee then.
Lucia: 太难了
Lucia: It's too difficult.
Tasha: 速度感觉他俩是不是也可以这样
Tasha: Doesn't it feel like they could do this too?
Tasha: 就一点点就成这样了
Tasha: Just a little bit and it's already like this.
Tasha: 怎么回事
Tasha: What happened?
Tasha: 大家挤一挤
Tasha: Everyone squeeze in.
Lucia: 哈哈电不够了
Lucia: Haha, the power's running out.
Tasha: 嗯大家积极勉强
Tasha: Hmm, everyone try your best.
Tasha: 哎就这样
Tasha: Oh well, that's it.
Lucia: 我觉得就是这样的哈哈
Lucia: I think it's just like this, haha.
Lucia: 非常对
Lucia: Exactly.
Tasha: 我感觉边是对了
Tasha: I feel like this side is correct.
Alice:但我感觉这有点大
Alice: But I feel like this part is a bit big.
Tasha: 嗯但是感觉这边要重新组合组合
Tasha: Hmm, but I think this side needs to be reassembled.
Tasha: 我觉得这边没问题
Tasha: I think this side is fine.
Tasha: 这边这边有问题
Tasha: This side, this side has a problem.
Lucia: 这几个好像都还挺挺符合的
Lucia: These few seem to fit quite well.
Tasha: 要把这几个重新组合一下
Tasha: We need to reassemble these few pieces.
Tasha: 但还是这几个边
Tasha: But still, these edges.
Lucia: 总感觉这个牛
Lucia: I always feel like this is awesome.
Lucia: 这里他应该能放一个什么东西进来
Lucia: Here, he should be able to put something in.
Lucia: 但是是的
Lucia: But yeah.
Lucia: 难道他也是一个
Lucia: Could it be that he is also a...
Lucia: 障眼法吗
Lucia: Illusion?
Lucia: 这个看起来其实也像在边上一样
Lucia: This actually looks like it's on the edge too.
Lucia: 看就是如果如果这样的话是吧
Lucia: Look, if it’s like this, right?
Katrina:  你这个花瓶呢
Katrina: What about your vase?
Katrina:  快递在哪看到的哦
Katrina: Where did you see the delivery?
Tasha: 花瓶不是快递
Tasha: The vase isn't from the delivery.
Alice: 就在桌子上
Alice: It's on the table.
Alice: 有两个瓶子
Alice: There are two bottles.
Tasha: 哎这个哎我买了6啊
Tasha: Oh, this one, oh, I bought six.
Jake: 哪一个
Jake: Which one?
Alice:取得了历史性的进步啊
Alice: Made historic progress.
Lucia: 历史性的进展
Lucia: Historic advancement.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 对我们刚发现这是这样的
Lucia: Yeah, we just realized this.
Lucia: 然后这样又可以拼上哦
Lucia: And then we can piece it together like this.
Tasha: 历史性的进步
Tasha: Historic progress.
Lucia: 不错不错
Lucia: Not bad, not bad.
Lucia: 胜利在望哈哈
Lucia: Victory is in sight, haha.
Shure:  这个跟这个上的
Shure: This with this.
Alice: 但是这感觉
Alice: But this feels...
Lucia: 这个有可能在里面
Lucia: This one might be inside.
Lucia: 感觉它看起来好像都不太圆对吧
Lucia: It doesn't look very round, right?
Tasha: 嗯先把它放
Tasha: Hmm, let's put it down first.
Lucia: 熊猫哎这个也很像在边上
Lucia: Panda, this one also looks like it's on the edge.
Lucia: 有道理
Lucia: Makes sense.
Katrina: 确实发了三个快递
Katrina: Indeed, I sent three packages.
Katrina:  但是都到了
Katrina: But they all arrived.
Alice: 你们换个边
Alice: You guys switch sides.
Alice: 更不像哎
Alice: It's even less likely now.
Tasha: 这个感觉屏有点那种弧度是他吗
Tasha: This screen feels a bit curved, is it this one?
Alice: 不是不是这个也不是
Alice: No, no, it's not this one either.
Lucia: 如果把那个鸟嘴冲着那边就是
Lucia: If we point the bird's beak that way, it fits.
Lucia: 这样的话嗯好像也放不进去
Lucia: This way, hmm, it still doesn't fit.
Lucia: 这些东西有可能吗
Lucia: Could these things possibly fit?
Lucia: 怎么会弄
Lucia: How does this work?
Lucia: 哇哇
Lucia: Wow, wow.
Alice: 太难了拼图天才
Alice: This is too hard, puzzle genius.
Lucia: 哈哈天才又找到一块
Lucia: Haha, genius found another piece.
Tasha: 拼图天才
Tasha: Puzzle genius.
Tasha: 出世出山
Tasha: Emerging from seclusion.
Lucia: 让我们看看有没有可能
Lucia: Let's see if it's possible.
Lucia: 在不依靠
Lucia: Without relying on...
Lucia: 解析的情况下
Lucia: Analysis.
Alice: 有点大
Alice: It's a bit big.
Lucia: 这个呢有可能吗
Lucia: How about this one, could it fit?
Alice: 不太行
Alice: Not really.
Lucia: 现在谁在中间呢
Lucia: Who's in the middle now?
Tasha: 嗯刚刚这个好像不太行
Tasha: Hmm, this one didn't quite fit earlier.
Alice: 他又跟谁分家了
Alice: Who did he split up with again?
Tasha: 对他他在这
Tasha: Yeah, he's here.
Tasha: 哎把小伙伴丢了
Tasha: Oh, he lost his little buddy.
Lucia: 哦这个这个这个在他的
Lucia: Oh, this one, this one, this one goes...
Lucia: sorry忘记了
Lucia: Sorry, I forgot.
Lucia: 嗯对这是这样子的
Lucia: Hmm, yes, it goes like this.
Lucia: 对对对这块就这样挺好
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, this piece goes here, it's good.
Tasha: 这样子挺好的
Tasha: Yeah, this is good.
Tasha: 这个
Tasha: This one...
Tasha: 这个还不确定在哪
Tasha: This one, not sure where it goes.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 确定在放中间吧
Tasha: Let's put it in the middle for now.
Alice: 你觉得这个像不像
Alice: Do you think this looks like it?
Lucia: 像嗯
Lucia: Yeah, it does.
Tasha: 好好先找找你的位置
Tasha: Alright, first find your spot.
Lucia: 应该就是他
Lucia: It should be him.
Lucia: 那边的呢
Lucia: How about over there?
Shure:  还有管家
Shure: And the butler too.
Alice: 那他能把我的送来吗
Alice: Can he bring mine over?
Jake: 什么东西啊
Jake: What is it?
Jake: 把什么东西
Jake: Bring what?
Tasha: 把我买的东西
Tasha: The stuff I bought.
Tasha: 那应该是很好的
Tasha: It should be really good.
Jake: 可以啊今天会有吗没有
Jake: Sure, will it be today?
Jake: 我问一下他们什么时候能
Jake: Let me ask when they can deliver it.
Jake: 能来送
Jake: When they can deliver.
Alice: 好这游戏三个人玩刚刚好我们的
Alice: This game is perfect for three people.
Alice: 掌管120组
Alice: Managing 120 groups.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 不太像
Lucia: Not really.
Alice: 他俩是不是一家的
Alice: Are those two from the same family?
Tasha: 他们仨是不是一个家的
Tasha: Are those three from the same family?
Lucia: 有可能但是总觉得哎
Lucia: Maybe, but it just feels like...
Lucia: 这里是不是应该稍微弧度再推一点
Lucia: Shouldn't this part have a bit more curve?
Tasha: 可是感觉不是那么严丝合缝
Tasha: But it doesn't fit perfectly.
Tasha: 他们俩的宽度最匹配
Tasha: Their widths match the best.
Lucia: 然后放一下
Lucia: Then put it down.
Tasha: 抱着这个呢
Tasha: Holding this one?
Tasha: 这两个都有可能
Tasha: Both of these are possible.
Tasha: 哎你觉得这个像不像在这
Tasha: Hey, do you think this fits here?
Tasha: 这样子的这样
Tasha: Like this, like this.
Lucia: 是这样的应该是
Lucia: It should be like this.
Alice: 不过这个头对着他的屁股
Alice: But this head is facing his butt.
Alice: 好像也挺颜色合缝的
Alice: Seems to fit pretty well.
Tasha: 这个这个是对的
Tasha: This one is correct.
Lucia: 对对这两应该是在一起的
Lucia: Yeah, these two should be together.
Tasha: 咱俩配对啊
Tasha: Are we pairing up?
Shure:  要不咱装个鸡
Shure: Should we assemble a chicken?
Jake: 好给你买一个台电脑
Jake: Okay, I'll get you a computer.
Jake: 从头装哇
Jake: Build it from scratch, wow.
Shure:  怎么出来的
Shure: How did it come out?
Tasha: 这个是吗
Tasha: Is this the one?
Alice: 有长这样的吗
Alice: Does it look like this?
Tasha: 没有吧
Tasha: I don't think so.
Lucia: 这个也有点像
Lucia: This one looks a bit like it too.
Lucia: 嗯因为好像长这样的
Lucia: Yeah, because it kind of looks like this.
Tasha: 这个暂且配对吧
Tasha: Let's pair this one for now.
Alice: 这我感觉这样应该
Alice: I feel like this should...
Alice: 这啥意思
Alice: What does this mean?
Alice: 很勉强但不是不行
Alice: It's a bit forced but not impossible.
Tasha: 这个跟谁都能配
Tasha: This can pair with anything.
Tasha: 这个
Tasha: This is our combined IQ.
Tasha: 我就说我是个拼图天使
Tasha: I told you I'm a puzzle angel.
Lucia: 哇，你真的是拼图天才
Lucia: Wow, you really are a puzzle genius.
Alice: 我这个在亮吗
Alice: Is mine glowing?
Alice: 为什么感觉这是粉色的
Alice: Why does it look pink?
Jake: 是红色你这电量太少了
Jake: It's red, your battery is too low.
Jake: 我看一下你的这个电在哪啊
Jake: Let me check where your battery is.
Shure:  这个是我我看一下这个对
Shure: This is mine, let me check this. Yeah.
Shure:  放下面的
Shure: Put it below.
Alice: 这在录吗
Alice: Is this recording?
Jake: 这个在录
Jake: Yes, it's recording.
Jake: 然后这个正在拉
Jake: And this is pulling.
Jake: 所以没关系
Jake: So it's fine.
Jake: 然后吧对
Jake: And then, yeah.
Jake: 这就是电开关
Jake: This is the power switch.
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Jake: 这是干嘛的嗯
Jake: What's this for, hmm?
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Katrina:  游戏
Katrina: Game.
Katrina:  高度调节
Katrina: Height adjustment.
Jake: 安装图这个样子
Jake: The installation diagram looks like this.
Jake: 这样是吧
Jake: Like this, right?
Jake: 这两个是这这是这嗯
Jake: These two are... this is... hmm.
Jake: 下面这是什么
Jake: What's below this?
Jake: 下面还有一条
Jake: There's another line below.
Katrina:  你把它反过来是不是这
Katrina: If you flip it over, isn't this it?
Jake: oh
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  holy shit what
Shure: Holy shit, what?
Shure:  what
Shure: What?
Shure:  耶哈哈哈哈
Shure: Yeah, hahaha.
Lucia: 嗯不行
Lucia: Hmm, no way.
Tasha: 他俩好像是一起的
Tasha: They seem to be together.
Tasha: 可能原本不是挨着这个屁股对
Tasha: Maybe they weren't sitting like this before.
Lucia: 这样的话
Lucia: In that case,
Lucia: 是他
Lucia: It's him.
Tasha: 可能他不在这
Tasha: Maybe he's not here.
Lucia: 有可能
Lucia: Could be.
Jake: 然后这个
Jake: And then this one,
Lucia: 如果真的在一块的话
Lucia: If they are really together,
Lucia: 可能就变成这样了
Lucia: it might turn out like this.
Lucia: 但是我找不到了
Lucia: But I can't find it.
Tasha: 从中间这个如果没有的话就不是对
Tasha: If it's not in the middle, then it's not right.
Lucia: 嗯好难呀
Lucia: Hmm, it's so difficult.
Alice: 确实
Alice: Indeed.
Tasha: 是他们俩对还是他们俩不这样
Tasha: Are they right or not like this?
Lucia: 有点难搞
Lucia: It's a bit tricky.
Lucia: 感觉拼困了累了歇一歇
Lucia: I feel tired and need a break.
Lucia: 哎怎么突然拼那个需要帮忙呢
Tasha: Hey, why do you suddenly need help with this?
Lucia: 看一眼
Lucia: Take a look.
Jake: 你们拼完了
Jake: Have you guys finished?
Lucia: 没有
Lucia: No.
Jake: 先休息一会是吧
Jake: Take a break first?
Jake: 对听困了
Jake: Yeah, it's tiring.
Lucia:  决定看看有没有什么其他可以帮忙的
Lucia: Decided to see if there's anything else we can help with.
Jake: 我们房间要不要
Jake: Do you want to do our room?
Jake: 我可能要装饰一下
Jake: I might need to decorate it.
Jake: 要不我们踩个风
Jake: Or we can take a look around.
Lucia: 也可以
Lucia: Sure.